شعبيه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على المحك
حتى داخل حزمه تراجعت نسبه تاييد الناخبين
الديمقراطيين له بشكل قياسي وتعرض لهجوم
وانتقادات لسياساته وقراراته بصوره علنيه
في انتخابات التجديد النصفي وضعت بيض
وحزبه امام خيارات صعبه
الديمقراطيون لا يرغبون بخساره اغلبيتهم
امام الجمهوريين وبداوا في لعب استراتيجيه
جديده انقلبوا فيها على بيض وبداوا بالقاء
اللوم عليه باخفاقات شهدها منتصف ولايته
للملف
الديمقراطي وعضو مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
برنيساندرز تحدث في صحيفه ديكاردين
البريطانيه عن ضروره ان يصب الحزب
الديمقراطي وتركيزه على الفوز من بوابه
الاقتصاد وان يقدم اجنده مؤيده للعمال
واحتياجاتهم
الرئيس الديمقراطي الاسبق باراك اوباما
حضر من جهته ايضا الديمقراطيين من التركيز
الكبير على الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في
انتخابات منتصف المده واقترح عليهم
التركيز على القضايا الجوهريه التي يهتم
بها معظم الناخبين
ويرى خبراء بان التحركات الديمقراطيين رغم
انها تفهم كانتقاد مباشر لاجدده بيض
السياسيه الا انها محاوله لركب الصدع داخل
الحزب ذاته وتفادي تشد الحزب في حال
خسارته امام منافسه الجمهوري في
الانتخابات النصفيه
[موسيقى]
قدامه
وينك وينك
[موسيقى]